What are my feelings about serendipity
versus gumption?
Uh,
luck versus elbow grease?
When do you give up on your dream when
you throw in the towel,
et Cetera?
Um,
there's an old quote that I attribute to
Tom Waits,
but I believe,
uh,
it might go back to socrates.
Um,
luck is when opportunity meets with
preparation.
And,
uh,
I've always found that deeply moving
because Megan and I talk a lot.
My wife and I talk a lot about how lucky
we are.
Um,
we're,
we're both blessed with whatever it is.
She's beautiful and an,
uh,
an incredible actor and smart as a whip
and,
and a really talented singer.
Um,
I can carry a great deal of luggage and,
uh,
I can experience extreme temperatures
for a long time without any sustenance.
Um,
we have our gifts and somehow our paths
have taken us to places where people
said we were looking for someone who can
carry luggage.
Uh,
we're doing a play about a donkey.
You're the guy.
And,
um,
and so,
I mean,
so much serendipity plays into it.
I,
I lived,
uh,
I chose to live like an asshole for some
years.
And it's a tough choice.
It's its borders on irresponsibility.
You know,
I,
I would be just this side of broke,
so sometimes I'd run out of money and
I'd have to borrow a month's rent from
my friend,
but I would then find carpentry work and
pay my friend back.
So I was just this side of being a
deadbeat.
I was flirting with dead beat ism.
And it's a big question in Hollywood and
a lot of people make a lot of money off
of people's dreams.
You know,
you can pay a great deal of money for
headshots and for acting classes and
coaching and life coaching and personal
training and all that stuff.
Um,
and that they'll all tell you.
And,
and there,
there are really gross people who claim
to have the secret,
uh,
come to my acting workshop and I'll have
three casting directors.
They're from,
you know,
one of them was an assistant on 50
shades of grey matter,
um,
and w whatever the case may be.
It's a question people wrestle with all
the time.
Will I ever make it?
Is it ever going to happen for me?
When should I throw in the towel and
moved back to Cleveland and see my
family and my children and my
congregation?
And I'm a priest with kids and
Cleveland.
And so,
uh,
all I can say is it's,
you know,
it's very,
it's a very personal thing to each their
own.
You got to keep working hard.
Um,
we've talked about having a discipline.
If acting is your bag.
Um,
you know,
I always tell people if they say,
how can I get my kid to where you are?
I say take up woodworking but also find
whatever stage,
find the biggest stage you can that you
can get onto and perform in front of an
audience,
whether you're doing standup or theater
or musicals or sketch comedy,
um,
or,
uh,
start shooting stuff.
You know,
now we live in an in an age where you
can literally start your own TV channel
right now using your gadgets and a,
and just let the world tell you,
you know,
um,
shoot videos.
Show them to people and they'll tell you
if you should keep doing it.
And if you're good,
if something's meant to happen,
when you,
when people see you on stage or they see
your videos,
they'll say,
holy,
you know what?
I'm going to somehow help you.
That was amazing.
I didn't,
you can tap dance.
You can play the Tuba that face you
make,
whatever it is.
I've never seen anyone drink that much
beer.
In 90 seconds I'm going to call my
friend.
He has a show called Jackass.
We're going to get you on your way.
And so,
I mean,
I started in the theater.
Uh,
I was terrible at acting.
I wanted to be an actor.
I thought I had something that I could
entertain people.
Um,
so I got into theater school in Illinois
and I was terrible.
I couldn't get cast with good reason.
The reason was I didn't trust myself.
Um,
I thought I was boring.
So I was from the country.
And so I tried way too hard to be
someone cooler than myself,
which of course just was,
was what they call bad acting.
But I was able to build scenery.
I was very athletic,
so I choreographed fights and the
theater paid me.
I found that there's so many jobs you
can do in the theater.
You can work in the box office,
you can sell concessions,
you can sweep,
there are many places,
almost anywhere you would want to work
in a creative position.
You can start there sweeping and curate
your sweetening.
Don't,
don't look down on if somebody is like,
well you could start as a janitor if you
want to work at Nike and you can get in
there as a janitor,
MPR,
show people how creative you're sweeping
is.
Nobody ever moved to that cabinet.
Move that damn cabinet and sweep under
it and let someone be like,
Oh yeah,
I just,
I assumed that everyone has the quality
of work that I do.
Let people see how committed you are to
two exceptional work when people,
because when you don't do a good job
sweeping,
I noticed that too.
And I say,
I'm not going to trust that person on
their own.
They always need to be told to move the
cabinet and sweep under it.
So,
I mean,
if you maintain that sensibility,
it makes you first of all make sweeping
a lot more fun.
Sweeping can be drudgery or it's an
opportunity to like have fun whistle a
song in your head.
You can dance with a broom.
They're really fun.
Um,
in fact,
maybe that's a a video line I should
think about putting out all different
genres of music,
all different brooms,
sweeping for pleasure.
Um,
but when you,
once you do that,
once you are locked into that mindset,
then you're open to when opportunity
comes along,
you've done the work.
You know,
if somebody wants to cast me as a
superhero,
this is sort of a truism in my life.
I've,
I've often said I'm athletic,
but I have often carried 30 or 40 extra
pounds and I think,
man,
I'd love to play a superhero.
And if someone would cast me,
then I'll go to the gym and get super
buff.
Well,
if I would just go to the gym and
maintain a discipline there,
then when someone said,
oh,
he's funny and he's the right type for
the superhero,
and check out those crazy less that,
then the work is done.
That's what,
sir.
So serendipity involves it.
Serendipity has greatly helped by,
uh,
by elbow grease.
And that reminds me of another quote
from Thomas Jefferson.
I think
that I won't remember.
Good look.
Okay.
Something in the vein of a good luck is
hard to come by,
but,
but when I work hard,
I f I find a much more susceptible to
experience luck.
He didn't say that I said it.
Nick Offerman said that quote.
Put that on a coin.
Okay.